que lorsque l'on parle d'internet au sens large,
toutes les solutions sont bonnes
si elles peuvent améliorer la sécurité de l'Amérique.
Et à mon avis, c'est sur ce point,
que les opinions sont si divisées,
il y a beaucoup de gens dans cette pièce
et dans le monde
qui ont une idée très différente d'internet.
C'est pour eux une invention prodigieuse
de l'humanité,
au même titre que l'invention de l'imprimerie
par Gutenberg, par exemple.
C'est la connaissance à portée de tous.
C'est un lien entre tous.
Et c'est ressenti de cette manière idéaliste.
Et de ce point de vue,
ce qu'a fait la NSA s'apparente
à ce qu'auraient pu faire, en leur temps,
les autorités allemandes
en insérant un dispositif
dans toutes les presses,
qui aurait permis de savoir qui achète quoi et qui lit quoi.
Pouvez-vous envisager cela de ce point de vue,
cela paraît monstrueusement choquant ?
RL : Je comprends tout à fait cela,
et je partage le point de vue sur l'utilité d'internet,
j'ajouterais même que ça va au-delà d'internet.
C'est un système de télécommunication mondial.
Internet n'est que la partie émergée de l'iceberg,
mais il y a bien plus.
Je pense que les gens ont tout à fait le droit de s'inquiéter
de l'équilibre qu'il doit y avoir entre transparence et opacité.
Cela a été formulé comme si il s'agissait
d'un équilibre entre vie privée et sécurité nationale.
Je ne pense pas que ce soit la bonne manière de voir les choses.
Je pense qu'il s'agit réellement de ce qui est transparent et de ce qui est secret.
C'est le débat national et international actuel,
nous voulons y prendre part, et nous voulons que les gens
y participent en étant informés.
Donc il y a des choses,
permettez-moi de parler de cela un peu plus longuement,
il y a des choses sur lesquelles nous devons être transparents :
nos autorités, nos procédures,
notre surveillance, qui nous sommes.
Nous, la NSA, n'avons pas fait du bon travail de ce côté-là,
et je pense que c'est en partie, la raison pour laquelle,
cela a été une telle révélation,
et cela a fait autant sensation dans les médias.
Personne ne savait réellement qui nous étions.
Nous étions la « No Such Agency » [Une telle agence n'existe pas],
la « Never Say Anything » [Ne dit jamais rien].
Il y a des caricatures de notre logo
un aigle qui porte des écouteurs.
C'est l'image que le public a de nous.
Nous nous devons d'être plus transparents concernant ces choses.
Ce sur quoi nous ne devons pas être plus transparents,
parce que ce n'est pas bon pour les États-Unis,
ainsi que pour tous les pays avec lesquels nous travaillons,
et que nous aidons à obtenir des informations
qui leur permettent d'assurer leur sécurité
et celle de leur population,
il n'est pas bon de mettre à jour les opérations et les capacités,
d'une manière telle que cela permettrait aux gens contre lesquels nous travaillons,
les criminels reconnus comme tels,
de les contrer.
CA : N'est-ce pas aussi
un mauvais coup porté aux entreprises américaines,
qui ont donné au monde la plupart
des services qui comptent sur Internet ?
RL : Oui, c'est vrai.
Cela met vraiment les entreprises dans une position difficile,
de même que nous,
parce que nous les contraignons à délivrer des informations,
comme le font toutes les nations du monde.
Tous les pays industrialisés dans le monde
ont des programmes d'interception de données légaux,
via lesquels ils demandent aux entreprises
de leur fournir les informations
dont ils ont besoin pour leur sécurité.
Les entreprises impliquées
se conforment toutes à ces programmes de la même manière
quand elles travaillent en Russie ou en Grande-Bretagne,
en Chine, en Inde ou en France,
quel que soit le pays dont on parle.
Le fait que ces révélations se soient faites dans les termes suivants :
« vous ne pouvez pas faire confiance à l'entreprise A
parce que votre vie privée devient suspecte avec eux »,
cela n'est vrai que dans la mesure où
c'est ce qui se passe dans toutes les entreprises du monde
qui traitent avec l'un de ces pays dans le monde.
Du coup, les gens l'utilisent comme
un argument marketing,
cela a été vendu comme ça dans plusieurs pays,
des pays alliés inclus,
où il se dit :
« Hé, vous ne pouvez pas faire confiance aux États-Unis,
mais faites confiance à nos entreprises de télécommunications,
parce qu'elles sont sécurisées. »
En réalité, ils utilisent cet argument
pour contrecarrer l'avance technologique
qu'ont les entreprises américaines
dans le domaine de l'informatique dématérialisée
et des technologies basées sur internet.
CA : Vous êtes assis là, avec le drapeau américain,
et la Constitution américaine nous garantit
la liberté contre les « perquisitions et saisies non motivées ».
Comment définiriez-vous le droit des citoyens américains à la vie privée ?
Ce droit existe-t-il ?
RL : Oui bien sûr, il existe.
Et nous y consacrons une quantité de temps et de force démesurée,
démesurée et nécessaire je devrais dire,
une quantité de temps et d'efforts dans le but
de protéger cette vie privée.
Au delà de ça, la vie privée des citoyens
dans le monde, il n'est pas seulement question des Américains.
Plusieurs choses sont en jeu ici.
Premièrement : nous utilisons tous le même réseau.
Mes communications,
j'utilise un service de courrier électronique
qui est aussi celui le plus utilisé par les terroristes dans le monde :
le numéro un.
Donc je suis juste à côté d'eux dans cet espace,
au sein d'Internet.
Donc nous devons être capables de séparer ces données,
et de trouver l'information qui nous est utile.
En faisant cela, il est évident que nous allons rencontrer
des Américains et d'innocents citoyens étrangers
qui sont simplement en train de faire leurs affaires.
Dans ce cas-là nous avons des procédures
qui écartent ces informations.
Elles nous disent, quand vous trouvez cela,
pas si vous trouvez ceci, quand vous trouvez ceci,
parce qu'il est certain que vous allez le trouver,
c'est comme cela que vous protégez cela.
Elles s'appellent les procédures de minimisation.
Elles sont approuvées par le Procureur Général
et basées sur la Constitution.
Et donc nous protégeons ceux-là.
Et donc, pour les gens, les citoyens du monde
qui vaquent à leurs occupations légales,
quotidiennement,
le président dans son discours du 17 janvier,
a énoncé un certain nombre
de protections supplémentaires que nous leur fournissons.
Donc je pense réellement,
que tout le monde a droit à la vie privée,
et que nous travaillons très dur
pour protéger ce droit.
CA : Que faites-vous des étrangers qui utilisent
les services Internet de compagnies américaines ?
Ont-ils un droit à la vie privée ?
RL : Tout à fait. Ils l'ont dans le sens où
il n'y a que trois cas dans lesquels nous pouvons
contraindre l'une de ces entreprises
à nous donner des informations :
lorsque nous pouvons identifier une personne en particulier,
identifiée par un certain type de sélecteur,
associée à la lutte contre le terrorisme, ou à la prolifération,
ou à tout autre cible de services de renseignement étrangers.
CA : Il a beaucoup été dit
qu'un grand nombre des renseignements obtenus
avec l'aide de ces programmes
sont essentiellement des métadonnées.
Ce ne sont pas vraiment les mots
que nous pouvons écrire dans un mail
ou utiliser par téléphone.
C'est à qui c'est écrit, quand, et ainsi de suite.
Mais certains disent,
et quelqu'un ici dans le public a parlé
à un ancien analyste de la NSA, selon lui
les métadonnées sont beaucoup plus invasives
que les données de base,
parce que dans les données de base,
vous vous présentez de la manière dont vous souhaitez.
Avec les métadonnées, personne ne peut dire
quelles conclusions vont en découler.
Qu'en est-il ?
RL : Je ne comprends pas vraiment ce débat.
Je pense que les métadonnées sont importantes pour plusieurs raisons.
Elles vous permettent
d'établir des liens entre les personnes
qui souhaitent les cacher.
Quand un terroriste entre en contact
avec quelqu'un que nous ne connaissons pas
mais qui soutient ou participe aux activités terroristes,
ou quelqu'un qui viole des sanctions internationales
en fournissant des armes nucléaires ou du matériel
à un pays comme l'Iran ou la Corée du Nord,
cette personne essaye de cacher ses activités
parce qu'elles sont illicites.
Les métadonnées vous permettent de relier tout ça.
Une gigantesque collection de contenu
serait une alternative à cela
beaucoup moins efficace
et beaucoup plus invasive en ce qui concerne la propriété privée.
Donc vu sous cet angle, les métadonnées,
sont en fait un apport positif pour le droit à la vie privée.
Et contrairement, à certaines choses
qui ont été écrites,
nous ne sommes pas là assis
à entrecroiser les métadonnées de tout le monde.
Si vous n'avez aucun lien
avec une cible précise des services de renseignement
vous ne nous intéressez pas.
CA : Donc en ce qui concerne les menaces
auxquelles l'Amérique doit faire face, en général,
à quel niveau situez-vous le terrorisme ?
RL : Je pense que le terrorisme est toujours la première de ces menaces.
Je pense qu'il n'y a jamais eu
autant de lieux où les choses se passent mal
et qui forment des substrats dans lesquels
les terroristes profitent du manque de gouvernance pour se développer.
Un de mes anciens supérieurs, Tom Fargo, Amiral Fargo,
avait l'habitude de décrire ça comme des « arcs d'instabilité ».
Il y a de nombreux « arcs d'instabilité » dans le monde en ce moment,
des endroits comme la Syrie
où, à l'heure actuelle, se déroule une guerre civile
et il y a un nombre important
des milliers et des milliers de combattants étrangers
qui vont en Syrie pour apprendre comment devenir des terroristes
et pratiquer cette activité,
beaucoup de ces gens sont des occidentaux
qui détiennent des passeports européens
et dans certains cas des Américains,
et ils sont essentiellement en train d'apprendre
comment faire le « djihad »
avec la ferme intention de partir
et de revenir le faire dans leur propre pays.
Il y a des lieux comme l’Irak
qui subissent une très forte violence sectaire,
un autre endroit favorable à la naissance du terrorisme.
Et vous avez aussi l'activité dans la corne de l'Afrique
et dans la zone du Sahel.
Encore une fois, des lieux où la gouvernance est faible
qui deviennent des terreaux fertiles pour les activités terroristes.
Donc je pense que c'est très sérieux, la menace numéro un.
Je pense que la menace numéro deux est la cybermenace.
Elle se décompose en trois points :
le premier et le plus connu
dont les gens ont entendu parler,
est le vol de propriété intellectuelle.
Des pays étrangers viennent,
volent les secrets des entreprises,
et par la suite fournissent ces informations
aux entreprises d’État
ou aux entreprises en lien avec le gouvernement,
pour leur permettre de faire de grandes avancées technologiques
ou pour accroître leurs compétences en informatique décisionnelle,
dans le but de gagner des contrats à l'étranger.
Ce sont des activités très coûteuses qui se déroulent à l'heure actuelle.
Plusieurs États-nations font cela.
Ensuite, il y a les attaques par déni de service.
Vous savez certainement qu'il y en a eu
une série dirigée contre
le secteur financier américain depuis 2012.
Encore une fois, c'est un État-nation qui mène ces attaques,
et ils font cela
sous forme de représailles semi-anonymes.
La dernière forme sont les attaques destructives,
et ce sont celles qui me préoccupent le plus.
Elles sont en augmentation.
Il y a eu l'attaque contre Saudi Aramco en 2012,
août 2012.
Plus de 35 000 ordinateurs ont été infectés
par un virus qui a tout effacé.
Suivie d'une autre attaque une semaine plus tard
contre une société qatarie.
En mars 2013,
il y a eu une attaque en Corée du Sud,
attribuée par la presse à la Corée du Nord,
qui a infecté des milliers d'ordinateurs.
Celles-ci sont en augmentation,
et nous voyons des gens s'intéresser
à ces possibilités
avec le désir de les employer.
CA : Bien, il y a plusieurs choses ici,
parce que c'est vraiment le cœur du problème, ou presque.
Tout d'abord,
beaucoup de gens qui regardent
le risque et les chiffres
ne comprennent pas cette croyance selon laquelle
le terrorisme est toujours la menace numéro un.
En dehors du 11 Septembre,
je crois que les chiffres pour les 30 ou 40 dernières années
sont d'environ 500 Américains morts à cause du terrorisme,
la plupart à cause de terroristes locaux.
La possibilité ces dernières années
de mourir à cause du terrorisme
est beaucoup moins importante que celle de mourir à cause d'un éclair.
Ce à quoi vous pouvez me répondre qu'un seul accident nucléaire
ou attaque bioterroriste ou autre
changerait ces chiffres.
Est-ce votre point de vue ?
RL : Hé bien, je dirai deux choses.
La première, la raison pour laquelle il n'y a pas eu
d'attaque importante aux États-Unis depuis le 11 Septembre,
ce n'est pas le hasard.
Nous avons travaillé très dur,
avec l'aide de beaucoup d'autres
au sein de la communauté du renseignement,
les militaires,
et tous nos alliés dans le monde.
Vous n'avez entendu parler
que de la partie émergée de l'iceberg
en ce qui concerne le nombre d'attaques terroristes
que les programmes de la NSA ont contribué à stopper,
54 en tout,
dont 25 en Europe,
et sur ces 25,
18 se sont passées dans trois pays,
certains sont nos alliés,
et certains de ces pays, d'ailleurs,
trouvent à redire sur les programmes de la NSA.
Ce n'est pas par accident que ces choses-là arrivent.
C'est du travail. Nous trouvons et échangeons
des renseignements sur les activités terroristes
et nous les interdisons d'une manière ou d'une autre,
en appliquant la loi,
grâce à la coopération avec d'autres pays
et parfois grâce à des actions militaires.
L'autre chose que je souhaite dire
est que votre idée de menace nucléaire ou bio-chimique
n'est pas du tout exagérée
en réalité, il existe un certain nombre de groupes
qui s'y intéressent depuis des années,
ils souhaitent obtenir ces technologies
et travaillent dans ce but.
CA : Il a également été dit,
que parmi ces 54 supposés incidents,
à peu près aucun d'entre eux
n'avait de lien
avec ces fameux programmes
mis à jour par M. Snowden,
que cela s'est fait à travers d'autres formes de renseignement,
que vous recherchez une aiguille dans une botte de foin,
et que ces programmes controversés
ont pour seul effet de complexifier ces recherches,
et ne permettent en aucun cas de trouver l'aiguille.
L'aiguille a été trouvée grâce à d'autres méthodes.
Y a-t-il une part de vérité ?
RL : Non, en fait nous parlons de deux programmes en particulier.
Le premier est la Section 215
du programme de métadonnées de la téléphonie américaine,
et l'autre est communément
appelé le programme PRISM,
c'est en réalité la section 702 de l'amendement FISA.
Mais le programme 215
n'est adapté qu'aux menaces
directes contre les États-Unis,
il y a eu une douzaine de menaces
dans lesquelles il a été impliqué.
Maintenant vous verrez des gens dire publiquement
qu'il n'y a pas de lien de « cause à effet »,
il n'y a aucun cas pour lequel
la menace ait été mise à exécution.
Mais cela dénote un manque de compréhension
de la manière dont fonctionne la surveillance terroriste.
Pensez à ce que voyez à la télévision,
quand vous regardez une enquête concernant un meurtre.
Par quoi cela commence-t-il ? Par un corps,
et ils partent de là pour résoudre le crime.
Nous travaillons en amont,
avec de la chance, avant qu'il y ait des cadavres,
et nous cherchons des solutions
en fonction des personnes auxquelles nous avons à faire,
en fonction de ce qu'ils essayent de faire,
et cela demande une grande quantité d'informations.
Pensez à une mosaïque,
et est impossible de dire si une partie était indispensable
à la construction de cette mosaïque,
mais pour réaliser l’œuvre en entier,
vous avez besoin de toutes les fractions d'information.
En ce qui concerne les menaces qui n'étaient pas destinées
directement aux États-Unis
42 sur les 54,
le programme PRISM est tout à fait adapté,
et nous a aidés concrètement
à arrêter ces attaques.
CA : Snowden a dit il y a deux jours,
que le terrorisme a toujours été
« une bonne excuse pour l'action » dans le monde des renseignements.
C'est un sujet qui fait appel
à un émotionnel très fort chez les gens,
cela permet de mettre en place ces programmes
qui confèrent à une organisation comme la vôtre
des pouvoirs qu'elle n'aurait pas autrement.
Avez-vous des débats en interne à ce sujet ?
RL : Oui.
Nous parlons de cela tout le temps,
il y a un débat en cours
entre la branche exécutive
et au sein même de la NSA
et la communauté du renseignement
sur ce qui est juste, adapté,
ce qu'il est correct de faire.
Il est important de signaler
que les programmes
dont nous sommes en train de parler
ont tous été autorisés par deux présidents différents,
deux partis politiques différents,
deux fois par le Congrès,
et par des juges fédéraux à 16 reprises.
Ce n'est pas la NSA qui prend ces décisions
de manière unilatérale.
C'est une activité légale
du Ministère des Affaires Étrangères du gouvernement des États-Unis,
approuvée par les trois branches
du gouvernement des États-Unis,
et dont le Président Madison aurait été fier.
CA : Pourtant, quand les membres du Congrès
ont découvert ce qui se passait avec leur autorisation,
beaucoup d'entre eux ont été très choqués.
Pensez-vous que ce n'est pas une réaction légitime,
mais une réaction seulement liée au fait que l'information soit devenue publique,
qu'ils savaient réellement ce que vous étiez en train de faire
avec les pouvoirs qu'ils vous avaient délégués ?
RL : Le congrès est une machine complexe.
Ils sont 535,
ils changent souvent,
en ce qui concerne la Chambre des députés,
c'est tous les deux ans.
Je pense que la NSA a fourni
tous les renseignements nécessaires à nos commissions de surveillance,
la diffusion de cette information à tout le Congrès
est gérée par les commissions elles-mêmes.
Je dirais que les membres du Congrès
ont eu l'opportunité de se rendre compte,
et un grand nombre d'entre eux,
ceux qui ont des responsabilités de surveillance,
avaient la capacité de le faire.
En fait, les présidents de ces comités l'ont affirmé publiquement.
CA : Vous avez mentionné la menace de cyberattaques,
et je pense que personne ici présent ne contredirait
le fait que c'est une grande préoccupation,
mais acceptez-vous qu'il existe un compromis
entre stratégies défensives et offensives
et qu'il est possible que les mesures prises
pour « affaiblir le chiffrement »
et qui vous permettent de trouver les méchants
puissent aussi ouvrir la porte à d'autres formes de cyberattaques ?
RL : Je crois deux choses.
La première, vous parlez d'affaiblissement du chiffrement,
moi non.
La suivante est que ces deux missions incombent à la NSA,
nous avons un caractère défensif très fort,
et en réalité, les faiblesses que nous décelons
dans la grande majorité des cas,
nous les transmettons aux personnes responsables
de la création ou du développement de ces produits.
Nous avons une grande expérience dans ce domaine,
et nous travaillons actuellement sur une proposition
pour être transparent et publier des rapports de transparence,
de la même manière que les sociétés Internet
sont autorisées à publier des rapports concernant
leur propre transparence.
Nous voulons être plus transparents au regard de tout ça.
Nous sommes utilisateurs de nos propres programmes.
Nous utilisons les standards, nous utilisons les produits
que nous recommandons,
il est donc dans notre intérêt
de protéger nos communications
au même titre que celles des autres.
CA : Edward Snowden,
après sa conférence, circulait dans les couloirs
à l'aide du « bot »,
je l'ai entendu dire à un couple de personnes,
qui lui demandait ce qu'il pensait
de la NSA de manière générale,
il faisait des compliments sur les gens
qui travaillent avec vous,
il disait que c'est un groupe
d'employés vraiment passionnés
qui veulent faire les choses bien,
et que le problème vient de politiques mal conçues.
Il est venu de manière très raisonnable et calme.
Pas comme un fou.
Diriez-vous, même si vous êtes en désaccord
avec la manière de faire, qu'il a au moins
ouvert la discussion sur un sujet très important ?
RL : Je pense que cette discussion est très importante.
Je n'aime pas la manière dont il a fait ça.
Il y avait d'autres manières de procéder
qu'il aurait pu choisir
et qui n'auraient pas mis les nôtres en danger,
ni des personnes d'autres nations,
en perdant de la visibilité
sur ce que font nos adversaires.
Mais je pense réellement que c'est
une discussion très importante.
CA : Il a été dit qu'il y a une différence de point de vue
entre vous et vos collègues
sur les différents scénarios
d'amnistie qui pourraient
lui être proposés.
Je crois que votre supérieur, le Général Keith Alexander,
a dit que « ce serait un exemple terrible
pour les autres,
vous ne pouvez pas négocier avec quelqu'un
qui a enfreint la loi de cette manière. »
Mais certains de vos propos ont été rapportés
disant que si Snowden pouvait démontrer qu'il restituait
tous les documents non divulgués,
alors, peut-être, qu'un compromis pourrait être envisagé.
Vous le pensez toujours ?
RL : Oui, en fait,
c'est ma partie préférée sur ces 60 minutes d'interview,
toutes les erreurs de citations qui viennent de là.
Ce que j'ai dit en réalité, en réponse à la question concernant
le fait que j'accepterais d'envisager des discussions
concernant l'atténuation des sanctions contre Snowden,
oui, j'ai dit qu'une conversation valait la peine.
C'est quelque chose dont le procureur général
des États-Unis et aussi le Président
ont également parlé,
et je m'en réfère au procureur général
parce que c'est sa fonction.
Mais il y a une forte tradition de jurisprudence aux États-Unis,
de discussion avec les gens qui ont été
inculpés de crime dans le but de,
si c'est profitable au gouvernement,
si l'on peut retirer quelque chose de cela,
il y a toujours une place pour ce genre de discussions.
Je ne préjuge d'aucune issue,
mais il y a toujours de la place pour la discussion.
Aussi profane qu'il semble être,
il semble avoir des choses à offrir aux États-Unis,
le gouvernement, vous, d'autres,
en terme d'équilibre des choses
et d'aide à la création de politiques plus adéquates,
avancer vers le futur plus intelligemment.
Voyez-vous cela comme
quelque chose de possible ?
RL : C'est en dehors de mes compétences.
Ça n'a rien à voir avec la NSA.
C'est le genre de choses qui incombent
au Département de la Justice.
C'est à eux de voir.
CA : Rick, quand Ed Snowden a fini sa conférence,
je lui ai offert la possibilité de partager
une idée qui méritait d'être diffusée.
Quelle serait votre idée à diffuser
à ce groupe ?
RL : Je pense que c'est connaître les faits.
C'est une discussion très importante,
et les retentissements, ne sont pas juste pour la NSA,
pas seulement le gouvernement,
c'est vous, ce sont les entreprises Internet.
Ce problème de vie privée et données personnelles
est bien plus important que le seul gouvernement,
donc il faut tenir compte des faits.
Ne comptez pas sur les gros titres,
sur les phrases toutes faites,
sur les conversations unilatérales.
C'est l'idée, je pense, qui mérite d'être diffusée.
Nous avons un symbole, un badge,
nous portons des insignes au travail avec un cordon,
et si je peux faire de la pub,
mon insigne dit « Dallas Cowboys ».
Allez Dallas.
Je viens de perdre la moitié des auditeurs, je sais.
L'insigne de ceux
qui travaillent dans l'organisation
et font du travail de crypto-analyse
comportent l'inscription « Regardez les données ».
C'est l'idée qu'il faut diffuser.
Regardez les données.
CA : Rick, il a fallu pas mal de courage,
je pense, pour venir et parler ouvertement
à cette audience.
Ce n'est pas quelque chose qui a été fait fréquemment
pas la NSA dans le passé,
en plus la technologie nous a joué des tours.
Nous apprécions vraiment que vous soyez venu
partager cette conversation extrêmement importante.
Merci beaucoup.
RL : Merci Chris.
(Applaudissements)